even breathing was like painful like
people could not find me if I were
caught they would send me back North
Korea it's like you know where the end
of Frank hiding in the house every
little move is a danger
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I'm in Oslo and I have
the privilege of speaking to North
Korean de facto activist author of the
books in order to live a North Korean
girl's journey to freedom and while time
remains Beyond me Park Beyond me thank
you so much for speaking with me today
thank you for having me on your show
well I've just read your your book and
this astonishing journey and I know
you've spoken about it a lot from North
Korea through China saved by Christian
Ministries taken to Mongolia then to
South Korea then to America and and now
I mean from that astonishing
start in North Korea and you wrote about
your father going to the gulag and the
Very Grim experience of your fellow
North Koreans and now in America but
also I find you in Oslo speaking at the
Oslo Freedom forum and it's rather a
change I I wondered how distant North
Korea felt you now looking back a bit
Yeah I think in a way sometimes I heard
like having time to like connect it a
lot of times it feels like I travel to a
different universe or at least like
different planet and first several years
I had a hard time to adjust it and now
it's been quite some time and I feel
quite adjusted to the new environment
thankfully oh that's good does it does
it seem somewhat miraculous to your your
journey absolutely it's unbelievable
because there are 25 million North
Koreans living in the country
and a lot of them go to China escape to
China and most of them trap there they
cannot get out of China and only about
like 209 of us made it to America 209
yeah over the last eight years wow so
statistically I don't know how lucky you
have to be among the 25 million to go to
America and even come to Oslo do you
feel a sort of responsibility and your
your your life now talking about North
Korea is that do you feel a duty to to
talk about what's happening there yeah I
think in a way the life that was given
to me me especially after crossing the
desert into Mongolia to be free yeah I
was always thinking about there got to
be a reason why I got saved and yeah I
really have the sense of you know
purpose in my story and it gives me also
a lot of hope you know what's possible
like my story cannot be possible in any
way logical sense and that's why I'm
hopeful for what can be possible for
North Korean people who are remaining
there there's that trip across the
desert of all the things is that the
thing that was the the hardest is that
when you when you mention it there is
that because that was the kind of nadir
of the of the ex of the Escape
yeah I think nothing ever taught me more
than that night being on the desert it
in a way you know even though
the world just abandoned me I was on the
world alone I was a completely invisible
from everybody else and I think Fighting
For Life fighting for dignity that's you
tell me so much about even gratitude
like that somebody knows me you know
that somebody sees me
so yeah when you say somebody who do you
mean by that because in China uh I had
to be invisible
I had to
even breathing was like painful like
people could not find me if I were
caught they would send me back North
Korea it's like you know where the end
of Frank hiding in the house
every little move is a danger right
so and then from there to going to
Mongolia in the middle of desert it felt
like everybody abandoned me you know I
was just alone fighting for my life
and now I'm here people know my name I
don't have to hide who I am I don't need
to look going on the street simply I
don't have to run away yeah and even
saying my name was a danger in China I
could not say any word we had to pretend
a lot of times we were a what is the
thing that you don't know how to speak
or
you didn't understand you're a foreigner
or no later sorry so a lot of North
Koreans try to survive by acting crazy
so if they're in the past people ask who
you who you are then you cannot say who
you are so they act like they are like
mentally ill literally or sometimes they
cannot say anything worse or they like
you know or like deaf we pretend those
things to survive but they would have
read they would recognize that you were
Korean and not Chinese right because our
Chinese are not good your Chinese not
good but also you're different people
let's you look you would look different
than China was that or is there a Korean
can is there a Korean in population in
that part of China it's you can I think
you pull that off look if you wear some
of Chinese clothes but once you say a
word that's when you give all the clues
so you cannot say anything what do you
um I'd like to understand North Korea a
bit because it seems to me even after
reading your book it's not just another
place it seems like an another time yeah
for sure
um and I I guess
I I kind of want to there's one
particular story in your book that stood
out and it was when well there's many
but one of them which was when Kim
Jong-il died and there was a mandatory
morning period and I and so I wanted to
understand whether and so people were
sort of forced to grieve right or told
to grieve yeah and I wondered whether
there were people in North Korea
um even amongst this sort of dire living
conditions who actually were grieving
who actually are sort of patriotic to
the the dynasty in power there and and
all is North Korea full of people who
actually hate it but can't say anything
because everyone
keeping quiet and not saying what they
think what's the what's the dynamic is
there a portion of each or is it one
swing one way
I think so that's the thing uh when I
was there I saw two deaths of kimira
song When I was a really baby and then
second was Kim jong-un's death when I
was like almost grown person
uh when the dictators dies people do get
shocked they think they are gods and if
my mother was so she's like a university
educated woman it studied like you know
chemistry science and she thought how
how does possibly God can die
and she thought that was the end of the
world orbit that's at the end of the
universe began she was very sad about it
and yeah and like in this period of they
say like even sometimes three years of
money or three months of morning and
that year morning that they put that
face and if somebody laugh and that's
how you send to concentration camp
just you cannot love entire that month
and month period and people do I think
people do get sad genuinely it's a lot
of research anyway absolutely she
mourned so much and actually Kim Jong-il
died after I escaped to South Korea yeah
and I was shocked even though I wasn't
living in Freedom I couldn't believe
actually he died were you was it was
there any sadness to it or was there a
sort of was a shock but happy that or
what would shock was accompanied by what
emotion so so in a way I believe that he
was immoral like I didn't think that he
would die and then first few time was
like shocked and second was you know my
happiest dream of North Korea when I was
living there was in my dream of meeting
him he came to my town I was meeting my
dear leader and that dream comforted me
through a lot of hard times in my life
being in North Korea so in a way for me
you escort literally my school teacher
teaches since we're tiny little like
child they say the most important thing
in your life is not your actual father
the biological father is not important
to you the most important person in your
life is our dear leader so he was the
most important person in my whole life
and I think that that's why the
saddening was there yeah but but by then
in South Korea I understood that he was
a dictator but in a way the mind like
your brain and heart moves differently
so whenever I see the picture of give me
a song with like his beautiful portrait
and around it like North Korean children
and flowers like my heart just like
fears were and respect wow and then my
brain kicks in like several seconds
later that's a fake portrait it's a
dictator brainwashing us so that's such
an interesting difference because you're
obviously such an outspoken critic of no
career perhaps the world's leading
critic of North Korea and yet you had
that in a sense of patriotism and so
do you think that the the the North
Koreans if that's generally held is that
what keeps the kind of communist
totalitarianism together that set that
sort of deep patriotism is that is that
what's keeping its somehow glued
together
I think several things connecting it
like one is really absolute fear and
zero tolerance you know there's a
Netflix series I think at the dictator's
handbook and talking about different
dictators and how North Korea is able to
maintain it that is where you get zero
tolerance complete brutality you do not
compromise in any single way you just go
for it kill them all three generations
eight Generations gets rid of every
possible seat that can reduce the
ideology
that is number one in North Korea like
it literally recently North Korean
regime sentenced two-year-old to
concentration camp
what two years can possibly do to
preserve that we work grounds because
the parents of this child had the on the
Bible
and North Korea is number one nation
that persecute your Christians so they
would send the literature two year old
to concentration camp the end of course
the three generations of their parents
gone together and I think this keeps
North Korea in a way intact because no
everybody knows they cannot Rebel this
old-fashioned stalinism yeah yeah but
like a lot of countries usually they
lose that grip they become soft and even
Libya like if you see other
dictatorships they become softer
eventually but North Korea was able to
Tire the fear every single time bringing
a more Medieval Times Dark Age method
and they are willing to do that you've
mentioned the Christian okay by working
there but you also talk about Kim
Jong-un as a god figure yeah what really
what role does religion have in in North
Korea is there is there a religion or a
metaphysic underneath Kim Jong-un
right so really North Korea is a the
regime is a religion right a capital
religion so what's interesting about why
they fear Christianity so much the kimer
song was really raised in a Christian
family and Pyongyang used to be a very
thriving Christian a time where there
are a lot of missionaries came from the
west and then kimerson when he became a
dictator he copied the Bible he copied
10 commandments and he said I love you
so much I'm giving you my son Kim zonia
his body dies but his spirit is with us
all the time that's how he knows our
thoughts what we think and that's how
people even afraid to think wow and
because he copied the Bible if people
read the actual Bible that was written
many thousands of years before him we're
gonna know that he's the fake that's why
he feels a Christian is so much more
but there are no existence of any
religion they officially say they allow
like freedom of religion but in reality
nobody can we don't even know what
religion means we don't even have the
word god
they deleted that word in our dictionary
so people don't even understand the
concept of believing in God wow so how
did the Bible that you described get
into is that are there Christians
quietly working or or you know preaching
or or reading scripture
in secret in underground is there a
Christian Movement so there is no
movement to alsoever in North Korea
there are 120 000 concentration like so
North has a different prison camps labor
camp where my father went and then
re-education Camp is where more like one
to five a year prison
and then concentrated in Camp in
concentration camp you go with your
entire generational family go there and
you cannot come out that's this sentence
usually you don't last even three months
once you stand there you die within
three months in this concentration camp
there are like more than 120 000 people
right now inside and 70 000 of them are
Christians
so every single one of them have a faith
go to prison and die there but the
despivers go through china such as the a
lot of South Korean missionaries go to
China and then find Smugglers and
smaller fibers inside North Korea and
then people who get the book they get
executed and sent to prison camps so the
books are coming in without preachers
the books are coming in alone so if
there's not uh you know you receive a
book like this and there's not someone
to tell you what the book is how do
North Koreans interpret or is it part of
a lot of books that are coming in yeah
so this is a thing where when North
Koreans escape to China the missionaries
Keep Us Safe in their life something
called safe houses underground and we
get trained to become Christians and
then the ones get really truly converted
the ones who are really die for God's
glory they ask them sometimes do you
want to go back North Korea give your
life to God and preach the Bible to
other people wow so some people go back
to North Korea to die for a gospel wow
that is the Christian Martyrs then yes
they are the ones and yeah thankfully
those Christians didn't ask us to do
that so we were able to go on freedom
but sometimes they do ask like do you
want to go back to North Korea and
preach gospel and then really die for
God's glory and some people do does any
part of you want to go back to North
Korea when it's free I mean absolutely
not if I go back I'm gonna get executed
right there yeah okay
um in I just read recently that suicide
according to South Korean intelligence
so it's we can't be sure that certain
that suicide rate is increasing in North
Korea they're saying a rate of 40 and
that to combat that Kim Jong-un is uh
it's holding local authorities
accountable if the suicide rate goes up
there to be punished yeah for that if
this situation is so big and people are
so desperate that they're killing
themselves in at such an increasing rate
it sort of implies that there's a lot of
people who would want a revolution or
the I guess the other option would be
revolution is is there any
possibility of that do you think there
could be anything that could turn the
regime over
so this is a how different North Korea
is from the rest of the world I was
listening to people coming from Ukraine
and talking about how war is the worst
thing can ever happen to anybody it's
true right now war is anything the worst
thing can ever happen to somebody right
as an individual citizen for North
Korean people that is the best thing can
ever happen to them because in North
Korea if you you commit a suicide
your family get punished yeah the
collective guilt right that the official
gets in North Korea you are not an
individual we are all part of group as a
collective so when the people in the
past could not kill themselves because
they were afraid if I kill myself I'm
gonna put a pain on entire my generation
and next generation and previous
generation and even the in-laws get
affected due to marriage
but now people get so desperate they
cannot even think of other people they
just kill themselves and the one thing I
was constantly hearing from nursing
people is like I wish what happened
today
that was every every day we're hoping
for because even were dying like by just
bullets was better than
putting that pain on our family members
if we kill ourselves and and Conjuring
is calling it a sin against socialism so
as well as him being the god of
socialism I guess is the is the
scripture yeah are you taught leninist
marxists thought in schools is everyone
educated in that philosophy right is is
that in in North Korea other in the
schools is that what everyone is is
taught
so initially they did teach the people
Marxism latinism you know the communism
and then they in the 1980s they found
their own ideologies
self-reliance ideology where we only
rely on ourselves because until today
the Marxism idea was the states take
care of people right you surrender your
property rights your your a lot of you
know the individuals that deserve you
give it to the state and for return the
state Gonna Give You Free Housing free
food in the future of the job that you
get free school all of it but then the
regime realized they cannot do that to
give it to people because they ran out
of money out of Soviet Union so they
found this ideology where something
called the self-reliance you cannot
trade you cannot own a property you
don't have any right but you need to
take care of yourself and you need to
take care of the state
and that's why you just they flip the
story afterwards
and now this idea of self-reliance where
people the regime don't take care of you
but you are forced to work for the
regime for free forced labor I see and
they they just completely enslaved you I
um there's another thing I've learned
about North Korea and there's a there's
a writer a British writer called Louise
Perry who actually I've had the pleasure
of interviewing as well but she wrote
recently that the existential threat to
South Korea is more urgent than for most
countries and this is on the topic of
birth rates right
total fertility fertility rate in South
Korea is 0.78 and its population is 51
million which were likely to decline to
just 15 million by 2100 yeah meanwhile
North Korea's population of 26 million
is expected to drop only slightly to 23
million in other words South Korea is
much poorer much much more authoritarian
neighbor is is currently Harvest
population size but within the lifetimes
of babies being born in Korea today yeah
that balance will be upturned
what do you what do you make of that do
you do you think uh how will that
demographic change affect the Korean
peninsula
so in a way that this fact shows a
testament how North Korean women are so
oppressed because we don't even know
what condom is
it's we are so poor like we we literally
I've never seen a trash can in my life
because we had nothing to throw away we
don't even know what shower is I've
never seen a world mattress in my life
we don't have like something called bad
linen you know we are sleeping on the
floor we've got a river to take a bath
and we don't take a bath in the winter
time
and North Korean regime something called
assigns marriages so men goes to
military women have to go to Military
and then when you don't even know of
course they say this uh this group
managed that group then they have to get
married it's not your by your choice and
when you get married because if you
don't know what to contraception it's
not your choice to have your
Reproductive Rights for you they have to
produce a child for the regime is it you
don't have a child for your family that
you reproduce and get married for the
stay sake that's why people are women
are forced to give birth even though in
North Korea we don't have formula so if
the mother are manually and doesn't have
the breast milk children die in North
Korea so many children die and if the
mother dies from childbirth the baby was
left alone we have seen so many men like
knocking the door my wife died can you
give some your breast milk to my child
but if the mother gives a breast milk to
somebody else their child will not
starved
so like the biggest regret to this day
my mom has is that they
she gave my two birds to me and somebody
in the hospital the woman did not have
any breast milk because of malnutrition
so she gave her milk to that baby
and then when I was hungry she didn't
have any milk for me
and she was like why I cannot believe
I've done that to you because the
Survivor is so hard
and this is why the North Korean women
have children not because there is more
opportunity in the society is better
for comparison South Korea women have so
much rights even though their society
might eventually collapse they still
have the right to choose not to give
birth sorry I don't understand the
reason why North Korean women have
babies it's not that they're choosing to
it's quite the opposite they don't have
a choice no they don't have a choice the
governments or signs you're married you
get married you need to have baby and is
that is there literally no support for
mothers what's the healthcare system
like in North Korea theoretically is a
free healthcare but there is no health
care because the doctors are starving
their average salary per month is not
even a dollar they cannot even eat
themselves so literally a nurse uses one
needle that is so thick and dull to
every patient there's no sanitation they
use a bitter beer bottle as a drop and
they they cut your bones without any
anesthesia and people people don't die
from cancer in nurse because you don't
last until that long you just die from
like mere infection and fever
so life expectancy is much lower than
South Korea what is life expectancy it's
really depending on the region but like
if my grandmother died before her 60 and
people said wow she lived a really long
time and they were like you don't need
to grieve because she lives so long and
now I come here people like in their 50s
they are like young yeah and my mother
who was 36 they called her like
grandmother from there on and here I
meet so many women at 36 hours not even
married in North Korea their
grandmothers they start calling Grandma
wow yeah that's that's astonishing um
what um what do you what what do you
think is sort of a preferable how would
you like to see things
go in North Korea like do you actually
you know you're here in Oslo advocating
for for North Korea but what can
actually what you actually in realistic
terms think can change there
so I have tried to work in the for the
last decade you know really solving the
symptoms of the vision we were like Mass
defection the people go to China like
like I was being sold like modern day
slavery as sex toys to these people and
I was really trying to rescue those
people but eventually the root of the
problem is the regime but that regime
exists because of Chinese support
if we do not change this piece policy
towards North Korea we are not gonna
have these people we don't change
America doesn't or Chinese China's
policy terms they literally sponsor
North Korean dictatorship they run the
dictatorship yeah why do they want it
what's it in their benefit because they
the China support North Korea they
without China North Korea would crumble
cannot exist right so what's it in it
from the point of view of the Chinese or
the CCP what do the CCP get from
supporting North Korea so there are
several things a literally miles his own
son to Korean War and he died
that's much how MA was investing in
Korea he lost his own son there
the relationship that China described in
North Korea is like between the relation
with your lip and your teeth
if you don't have your lip your teeth
gonna have all the air comes in and it's
you cannot eat things if you don't have
teeth of course you cannot chew So you
you're you cannot like you die so you
need each other to survive the reason is
that China has a lot of Independence
movements within China there are 56
different ethnicity we met the weakers
we met the Tibetans there's so many
people do not identify themselves as a
Han Chinese the vast majority are
handshiners right but there are a lot of
ethnicity that do not want to be part of
China yes
and so North Korea is a buffer zone
there is a South Korea down below and
there is Japan and across the ocean
there is America
that wave of movement of democracy
coming in at their door but North Korea
keeps that but for it so nobody in China
can see across the river at night what
we do like why they have freedom why
those people have so much more
Prosperity than us so North Korea keeps
stuff for them and then the second one
is a leverage stick against America
whenever North Korea tests missiles
where does America go to they have to go
to China to beg them to like North Korea
to diary down so it's a leverage stick
against America I see and also the third
one is like really North Korea make them
look so much better
the reputation wise as long as North
Korea exists next door so the Chinese
people go look it could be worse yeah it
could be so much worse publicity why is
so much better and also International
Society North Korea is so bad you are
not gonna much as focused on those
Chinese human rights issues
right do you when you describe the the
lips and the teeth uh that that sort of
analogy is that uh with a reference to
sort of communist Brothers across or is
it is it more ancient than that is is it
that they're the two Communist States or
they are two Communist States next to
each other is that is that the depth of
that relationship so that was what Mao
described his own party why it is so
important to defend North Korea they
send so many Chinese soldiers to die in
the Korean War fighting against America
and the U.N right and international like
Western Hemisphere they came into during
the Korean War but we need each other to
survive we cannot survive without each
other so at all costs we need to defend
North Korea I see and we need to keep it
as it is so that's the analogy he gave
you to the Communist party members and
told them why they we need to die for
North Korea eventually and he said his
own son to die for it wow what do you
think um the the correct response or the
correct policy is from say America
towards North Korea is there's
the kind of uh Dennis Rodman approach
where he goes over and he's friends for
life of King Johnson or there's uh Trump
who made a point of of being was he the
first president to go to a step foot
into North Korea yeah uh what what would
you like to see from the American
Country American regime in in
dealing with North Korea
I think America needs to be very strong
they need to understand their standing
in the world the China needs America
more than American is China America is a
very unique country they don't need
other countries to survive they have
their own order inside the country they
have such a big economy that they don't
need other countries in a way right even
though so much happening in the world
America as it is they can survive right
they are on unlike other countries
and
China's economy is heavily relied on
export and America is a huge partner in
that and if America stood up saying we
are not going to do trading with you if
you do not control North Korea like
North Korea is their goal is developing
a weapon that can destroy America
eventually they have already weapons
that can be rich mainland of America
already
and in a way like it's too big to fail
like eventually North Korea is capable
is so high if we are already there right
that North Korea capability is so high
that they can completely destroy Japan
and North Korea and China and South
Korea so nuclear weapons right with
their even just without any equipment
they have so many arsenary that they're
going to destroy South Korea especially
so that has like 50 million people
living there
I think because of America was so
apologetic and would not stand their
ground and do not call out China and so
many politicians okay because what is
the government what is a goal is a
collection of individuals who have so
much their self-interest
and they have so many lobbyists and
giving them helping them to get reacted
and those people give them money and
resources these politicians they have so
many people who make money with China
yeah so this policy when they get
elected they go to Congress yes they
don't they don't do the right thing they
do what's right for them
and I think this is the idea where I
somehow we think governments are better
than individuals they're somehow
Immortal bodies like they are just
collection of selfish people and did not
make the right decisions to this point
and now North Korea is truly too big to
fail they have so much capability we
cannot just like Iraq just go there
remove the dictator because really be in
danger like at least 50 million
subsequent people right like an hour
apart down there I sort of take that
answer to to mean that America's policy
to North Korea really is America's
policy to China primarily exactly what's
how do are you concerned about China on
the global scale very much I mean
imagine what we went through the
pandemic if they just came forth about
clearly what was happening and
transparently we could have saved so
much people or the resources are in our
time and the Damage they just cause try
like we learned the threat of China
through the pandemic and if that is just
the beginning it literally it's just the
beginning we have no idea what they're
having what's coming for us afterwards
and the fact that we don't like hold the
channel comfortable what was happening
with the pandemic right now that's
what's disturbing to me imagine this was
the job of America because this pandemic
to the world how they're going to
condemn us so much to our grave and
nobody condemned China because they are
all making money out of this evil regime
so it's a I think that's a thing because
we continue to see that in America and
everywhere there's people try to make
the money for themselves and don't do
the right thing
if I can just go back one step just ask
about North Korea because you're on the
board of the of the human rights
foundation and
um this year in February this year uh
the human rights Foundation announced
that a new North Korea program where
they were going to
extract information to monitor what's
going on within North Korea as well as
uh send in information to uh to to try
and ideas about liberal democracy to try
and maybe uh change people's opinion
from within yeah do you think that these
are going to be effective means of
actually
changing North Korea
it is a very good alternative option if
you the governments if the world leader
is not going to step up and asking China
to stop subspawns the northern regime
this is the best thing that Civil
Society can do because the water
extracting information means that North
Korean regime conducts so many illegal
businesses to make money and with that
money keeps the concentration camps and
that money especially spending on
building more nuclear weapons that is
threatening the entire humanity is it
throughout Humanity really but North
Korea is building so
they are gonna look for the information
that how North Korea makes that money
and we block them
and then North Korea is very scared like
evading sanctions and that's why we need
to be even more secure than them to find
out during dry that money going into the
dictator's hand and make it harder for
him to get more resource to build more
nukes and that's gonna be a battle but
it has is a very important battle to
have you talk about nukes and do you
really think that Kim Jong-un is
foolish enough to actually start a
nuclear war and if he was wouldn't the
Chinese wouldn't Xi Jinping say don't
you dare start what do you think he
would be so reckless do you actually are
you actually concerned that he would use
those weapons so inside North Korea when
I was growing up I like we were saying
How brave our the dear little Kim
Jong-un was he literally said there is
no word without North Korea
there's no Humanity without North Korea
if he really caught that means the
regime the Kim family literally if there
is a moment comes that he feels like
they cannot maintain their power
they're gonna blow it up I don't think
they are capability yet to blow up whole
world they were blob soul for sure and
maybe some Japan right back into a
corner you'd think that they would they
would but until that point I don't think
they were because they're not stupid
they're very logical they need a nuke
because they want to continue the power
they maintain the status quo they're
using it not to destroy somebody they
try to protect their own regime
so that's why they want to get a bit
bigger new bigger because that means
they have more protection that's why
they are keep building they put every
resources so basically testing one nuke
the equivalent of money that feeding
entire nation for an entire year
Kim Jong-un software conducted more than
15 nuclear tests if he did like four
less of them nobody had to die entire
time of misery from starvation but he
would not do that he put everything he
has to testimonial news and not feeding
people it's we talked earlier about the
diet state
of living conditions and life for North
Koreans and actually if
they're if the leaders are prepared to
tolerate such horrible conditions for
his people if the supreme leader is
happy to tolerate that then actually
it's not that much of a leap for him to
sacrifice the whole of North Korea I
suppose it actually reminds me of uh um
[Music]
Castro's autobiography is actually
written as an as an interview but he
publishes this letter exchange and he
says at one point
start the nuclear war the Cuban people
will be happy to sacrifice themselves
for the Communist Revolution and Soviet
Union's reaction was whoa Astro is crazy
yeah told Kennedy hey uh okay we need to
sort this out Castro's he's gone loopy
so if Kim Jong-un is that crazy might Z
and I've kind of already made this point
get him to just calm down is do you
think he respects jingping Xi Jinping
enough that he would listen to him
has to because China has all the keys uh
in a way so basically how their attitude
towards their own people so in the 90s
when I was a totally just born uh
there's a mass starvation going around
the country Millions over time and then
the officials would literally go to Kim
Jong yeah like dear leader people are
dying from starvation what should they
do and he said he was laughing let them
die it's easy to do socialism when there
are less of them
it's easy to control people when they're
less people that's why this Marxist
ideology hates people yeah this
anti-human sentiments and they think
humans are poison so hard to control
they don't want us that many of us to
control so that's why he was literally
laughing it's like let them die it's a
good thing for us to control them and
basically their policies there's a 10
living in Pyongyang the capital the
royal class the regime wants those
people only right so until the 90
percent dies off we are not going to
think about it so that's their problems
their tolerance stops IT awareness 90
dies off they're gonna only willing to
fight for that 10 of a core group that
supports the region wow and so you've
now come to live in America live in the
west and uh you have been writing in
your most recent book while time remains
it's critical of the West and
um uh it reminds me a little bit of when
Alexander sultanitson left the Soviet
Union he was expelled 1974 eventually
settling in in America in Connecticut
and he did a tour of universities and
and did these parade speeches which are
collected in a book called a warning to
the West now saltz nitson could have
been cut embraced as the hero an
American a a a a a a a sort of a Russian
who turning against the Russian regime
and instead he went to America and
criticized America he criticized their
shortcomings where where he felt they
were
failing their own people and it's
astonishing
essays to read as we just read but it
reminds me a little bit of yotun you've
come to America and now you're
criticizing a turn to authoritarianism
what what can you tell me about that
authoritarianism that you that you see
in the West
yeah I think that's very very
interesting because for me
Socialism or Marxism is not a theory
that I'm reading in a nice library with
air conditioning on it literally was my
daily life I knew how that was actually
penned out in reality not as a nice
theory in a textbook
and when I come to America there's so
many people who want that theory they
worship that theory and they hate
America
anti-freedom anti-america is so deep
rooted in American like left his Minds
that they hate American to Gods
literally in the University professor
says that the only solution for all
these problems is dismantling American
System
destroying America destroying Western
Civilization as we know it
and the alternative they wanted is not
even something different but we have
tried the Marxism collectivism socialism
the same ideology that destroyed every
single time it was tried yeah I think
that's why it's so scary how humans are
so dumb keep repeating the same mistake
do you have any observations about why
these ideas that you know to be
ludicrous and actually are evil yeah
um like communism is popular in some
quarters and socialism is very popular
in in the west why why is it that you
think that they are popular do you think
that comes from a sort of uh I don't
know a nihilistic about poor education
or or lack of experience
is it a different type of indoctrination
have you what have you perceived that
that is rooted in this is all of what
you just said like bad education lack of
experience of a real world and
perspective therefore and of course to
brainwashing the mass indoctrination
begins in public schooling in America
but why also then the first place that
begun right
I think
it's got to be solved in in a human
nature that wants to be taken care of
with something greater than themselves
because humans are so vulnerable think
about it you like us as an individual we
are so vulnerable so many little things
can easily kill us even so many things
can go wrong
and I think a humans desire that
protection yeah and I think in the past
we had a religion where we somehow
believe that there is a beautiful
amazing loving God sitting in the heaven
making sure that we are safe that we are
provided
and that gave us Comfort even though
that was a lot of times so to to control
people but it at least gave us comfort
that things gonna be okay even if we die
there is no behaven rating for us in
every religion they all have this
sentiment of going to great place after
death giving you that Comfort because
otherwise if you don't believe that life
meaningless so sad like you work so hard
and that's the end you become a dust you
become nothing right and then as a
society becomes more uh secular
we need to fill that void with something
and usually they want to feel that voted
to government
that very strong they have so much and
they can take care of me they can make
sure that I'm gonna be safe I'm gonna be
taking care of the hospital I'm gonna
get a good education and we're gonna
have a house to live in and it's a dream
and it's in a way so sad you know humans
are lonely it's it's a weird thing so
it's part of this you think part of the
death of God you know we talk about
secretary it is do you think America or
the west and certainly in my country in
Britain uh uh Christianity now minority
yeah
um of the population is is that the void
that's that's that you notice is
maybe the root of the issue yeah I think
it's a uh I became a mother in Freedom
and until that point I was atheist I
hated Dogma to my guts I hated like why
nothing if logically if I cannot see I
don't believe it because that's what
North Korean regime was it was a Dogma
they're controlling us
and then I will hated every religion I
was like I'm an atheist I don't believe
any people I thought the religious
people are the most dangerous people in
the world
and then when I became a mother
I would start praying really because I
wanted my child to be safe there's
nothing I can do to protect him and when
I was pregnant I was reading my
pregnancy book a million things can go
wrong with his development
you're so helpless yeah and the only
place that I could comfort was praying
yes I hope there is a God that taking
care of my child I hope there is a God
they're gonna make sure they don't have
a happy life
and that's the thing like that's when I
realized oh that's why people are
religious because it's a comfort that
you get right and because life is so
hard genuinely heart is a dangerous
place to be even even in Chicago
especially in Chicago I that's how I
lived in Chicago now I'm in New York
and I think that's why I was realizing
for the first time why people need a
religion it doesn't have to be a
Christian God or a British God it could
be something that you find a you know
the comfort in yeah and it's so sad when
they feel that Gap they feel like void
with the government because the
governments are literally the collection
of selfish people Liars sitting in and
saying that they are benevolent yeah
which they are not well they're not just
filling it with with government they're
also there's various new ideologies
transient geology a lot of workers and
seems to be a sort of surrogate religion
to feel that that go with that that
god-faced vacuum has your prayer taking
you to a specific religion or an
organized religion
I think no I I send my son to a even
Buddhist temple I go I love like I go I
love to go to places where I can be
humble and just pray if we baptize me
Catholic Church he goes to Catholic
church but it's not really like about
what sector it is at the moment
uh I think this is the thing when I
heard from Dr Peterson in uh 12 verse
for life you know like I live life as if
God exists yeah as if God is alive
because if it is it's a good thing
probably but even it isn't it's good to
conduct your life as if God is there who
has a moral figure who teaches you gotta
love your neighbor and forgive other
people and I think that's when I
realized religion doesn't have to be
that I see God every day yeah that just
live your life as God is real
and if life becomes so much I think in
my case it made my life way more
peaceful you know because then I don't
have to be too much anxious and
Lord that helped me at least so we go to
churches and how old is your child he's
five and a half he's five and a half
yeah he's starting pre-k this year and
is this faith is it helping you to to in
build a moral compass for him are you
are you referring to are you referring
to scripture or your whether it's
Buddhism or Christianity in order to
help him
form a moral uh structure yeah because
it's a in a way
that what scares me about America is a
they say like oh America has too much
freedom I don't like it I don't think
it's the problem is having too much
freedom then when when you read going
back to American founding fathers when
they built the country they said freedom
without virtue or in other words
discipline is anarchy Freedom needs
virtue and discipline and now what we
see in America is anarchy because they
lost that discipline and virtue back
then the scripture provided that virtue
to the people yeah and that's how
America was became birth through this
humanity and became this beckon of Hope
Now in America you're free so you can
shooting yourself up with the heroin
because you are free you cut off your
body part that's fine because you're
free you can do all of this there's no
right and wrong yeah and there's no
place to get that virtue and discipline
come from and I think that's when I
realized
my my child needs this yeah because I
don't want him to become more Anarchist
and think that he can destroy his body
and just conduct his life however he
feels not with the purpose but just
however you feel at that moment yeah
because American culture is all about
enjoying yourself all over living in the
moment not about building your legacy
and having a purposeful life just live
in the moment have fun yeah we've talked
about it there's some of the the
problems coming from the left in America
and I wondered if you had insight into
the failings of capitalism whether you
you think that the right of making
mistakes the conservatives are in error
and that's again that's what sultanity
was really criticizing it wasn't really
criticizing the left America he was
criticizing uh the the capitalistic
right I do think that joining of the
corporation in government especially
like this time we saw before elamas took
over you know Twitter Facebook they were
all working middle American government I
think that's a huge mistake in democracy
yeah you know this this cooperation has
so much power yeah and government has so
much power when they unite there's
nothing can stop them yeah and I do
really think there is a danger to
capitalism and but this is the thing
where like when I ask them oh what's the
problem with capitalism they usually
give the example of inequality
right like this the reason why Catherine
is so evil because there is a homeless
person and because there's a billionaire
it's not fair but to me that's not a
problem why I have a problem with
capitalism because the sign of
inequality is a sign of progress to
nursing person because in North Korea do
you know what happens if you want to
become a homeless what happens they send
you prison camp you have no right not to
work the fact that there is autonomous
to me is a sign of freedom the
individuals literally can choose not be
responsible I'm just choosing not doing
nothing productive right just want to be
on the stream laying down smoking pot
and showing them services like drugs
it's not the state fair then in a way
the self
they fear themselves and I don't blame
you a lot of times they have a mental
illness and situation is not right but
that is not because the capital is evil
because there's so much tolerance that
unlike dictatorships they don't put them
in a prison camp and rape them and
torture them and make them work in the
first labor camp so relatively obviously
it's you could say it's better but it's
still not a good thing it's not a good
thing but I don't think that perfect
Society is possible because we're born
with different capability like I'm a
mother it was so Random large kind of
child I'm gonna get what kind of
intellectual capability gonna have what
kind of tempers I get have what kind of
Hair Design you have right and as a
society we cannot take care of everybody
it's not a perfect Paradise shouldn't we
aspire to that is a usually a path to
hurt to me because we should not aspire
to a perfect Society however society
that has a responsibility for yourself
and your how make your bed taking care
of your health and then if you took care
of your body and your health and your
mental care then you can take care of
your family members then your community
it shouldn't be uh as a society a goal
to make sure that everybody's not
failing I think
that is a very compassion ideology that
is so trickable because it sounds like
so amazing it's so sad seeing people on
the street and suffering especially in
the cold and in the heat but whenever we
try to fix them all individually I think
that's when we really getting into we
need the NP government who can control
every aspect of Our Lives
and that is I think where is dilemma
begins because people really trying to
begin with a good intention but then who
do we want them to solve that problem
the government are they good at solving
problems of course not they create more
problems than solving it but that
doesn't mean one shouldn't try and solve
those problems at all as an individual
as a civil society you can join a church
you can join a community service if your
passion is homeless problem you can do
it as an individual Civil Society it
shouldn't be government forcing to tax
you and then try to create an industry
or people making money because there's
homeless people so through social
Enterprise rather than through
government I think I really believe that
we have a responsibility of everybody
else it'd be amazing world if we all
took that responsibility but it
shouldn't be forced by government they
shouldn't be taxing all of us because
they want to take care of because they
always fail we haven't tried do you know
how much the San Francisco spend on each
homeless person they fear they create
more problems than actually not and I
think this is where conservatives and
left in a conflict nobody deny that
that's bad nobody denied that but how to
solve it I think it comes down to
difference right like I would rather I
choose to do it and I will join
organization myself like joining hrf or
other organizations to do it then hoping
the government officer is going to fix
that problem for them absolutely you
mentioned earlier that your concern with
big government and big Tech yeah and
that and the sort of revolving door
between them and actually that was
Italian fascism that is the definition
of fascism is government and big
business in kahoots working in China
yeah and and so chronic capitalism
chronic Capital yeah exactly and and
what can how should significant issue do
you think that is is that something that
you're concerned about I'm very
concerned about that I really saw the
power in these corporations and then
governments when they work together
because nothing can stop them Google is
more powerful than a lot of governments
in the world already and when they work
with US Government how do we stop them
and I think that's why the the freedom
of speech was a weird under threat not
because uh just some one individual
cooperation thought you cannot say this
word this cooperation is so powerful
beyond the nation a lot of Nations and
then they work with the government to
decide what is a true and what is not
yeah and I think that is a danger of
capitalism and but that is not a true
religion it's a chronic capitalism yeah
and I think if we need to fight whenever
we see that when they gain too much
power there's no checking balances and
break them apart and it's going to be
harder and harder because they're gonna
have more power over time yeah and
government is going to eat more power
they grow so much already yeah and it's
gonna be harder to visit it's very
striking to hear you as a North Korean
who's concerned about free speech in in
the west have you experienced any
impingement on your personal Free Speech
because you know you're going around
using like someone whose speech is very
much free and and have you felt the
impact of uh censorship at all in in the
west not in North Korea so whoever did
we begin I need to write another book
I am still Shadow event even after Elon
Musk took over Twitter really yes and
what what for do you know no I don't
know even I just like a you know take a
picture of a strawberry and post it is
like a sensitive content because it's
coming from me really yes and I am a
crucial band I I don't have a you know
you know YouTube I have a YouTube
channel that has like now 1.1 million
people following me I if as soon as I
created a China
and support the second amendment that
that video get blocked demonetized and
get censored so I don't have a freedom
speech on Google and of course on
Instagram they put me in a jail
temporarily I get Charro bands and if I
behave I come out of the jail you know
it's like punishment system and you
think that's for criticizing China China
and of course criticizing some
transgender ideology where I criticize
is that you know uh people who are not
men like witches of women
world of women like people who have
periods women have periods
and they say I'm a transphobic person
because I believe that women have
periods and they think that's true
because they think men can have too
so this kind of you know speech gets me
in trouble but not only through this a
tech companies I was canceled by
corporations like Samsung Electronic U.S
company not the South Korean one I was
cast what did they do they scheduled my
talk and they said they my political
opinions are not aligning with their
values so they can certainly anything
that was to do with trans no I think it
was more China because they had a huge
investment in China and I was talking
about the horrible corruption the
Chinese government committee yeah so
that was China because of that because
China I mean they had a literally two
billion investment in Shenzhen and I was
criticizing Chinese role in coming this
crime against humanity against the
weakest yeah and North Koreans Tibetans
and so many even their own citizens the
Han Chinese get oppressed by their own
regime right Chinese are not free even
Han Chinese are not free they are under
the government's control yeah and then I
was literally can't answered by FBI they
invite me to speak and then two days
literally before my event the head of
diversity calls me what to do with the
head of diversity they said your
political opinions do not align with our
values so we have to cancel your speech
Puerto Rico my political opinion
political okay really wow and then do
you know what's funny about it I became
American last year and in my American
citizenship the lady asked me have you
ever persecuted anybody for their upper
opinion if I said yes I could not have
become American
so they don't even know what it means to
be American because they never took
American citizenship tests in America
people cannot get punished for their
political opinion and this organization
like FBI all the big tech companies and
corporations punish people because of
their political opinions wow that's
astonishing and do you think um anything
so we need a sort of change the FBI I
mean that's that's very a very deep
rooted that's governmental I mean it's
there's there are parallels with North
Korea it feels drastic to say it because
of how awful North Korea is but do you
think it's do you think things are have
any chance of getting better in America
or is it do you sense things are just
it's you live there it's it's it's a a a
country divided or do you think that its
core values of of free speech are not
cannot you know can eventually unite
everyone again are you hopeful for
America so it doesn't in a way they did
not earn their freedom the people who
were born in America they were born to
it because they were lucky nobody choose
their birthplace right and I fall for my
freedom in a way I was like when they
were censoring me we need to strip their
sensible way and send them to North
Korea right like it just makes no sense
but that's a joke really like we cannot
do that
I do think that's why we need the
freedom of speech we need to give people
to have advice so they can speak these
opinions and tell people that what it
means to be American what it means to be
in the Constitution that what is a
protected on the law yeah
but these organizations know any country
is a they can't follow the Tyranny
America is not immune to it Britain is
not mean to you every country is
possibly can become like North Korea
that the FBI persecuting somebody for
their perfect opinion is a spectrum of
North Korea right North Korea's attend
they literally execute you along with
two genes or your family America is
somewhere in the middle right in the
middle for sure like you you can lose
your job if you have a wrong political
opinion in America you lose your dignity
they character assassinate you they
literally on Twitter if you go they say
I'm a liar I'm a CIA spy I'm uh you can
call to say I spy yeah of course that's
the first thing it's like I'm like
American imperialist I'm always all the
people the Marxist people or the
professors yeah or like even in the
European countries that who hates
American imperialism I only compare
America's imperison right now but they
say America's imperialist country and I
support that there
yeah on a personal level when you have
the world
attacking you yeah
how do you deal with that how do you
cope with that it must be a tremendous
burden it is it's a some days is a
harder and some days is easier it's like
a back and forth you know either but
it's I did not know quite how many
people were sympathetic to the idea of
equity which is a collectivism right
like
and when you crisis Equity you sound
like such a horrible compassionist like
heartless person yeah right like they
are acry means let's give everybody
equal opportunity and equality of
outcomes
and then like that's impossible you
cannot see the same result right even
people from North Korea
we all have different results in the
society yeah not because American system
is intolerant because we all had a
different capability yeah to come here
and we made a different result it's
impossible to government to fix that and
and people really hate me for that
especially people on their left and even
some Democrats think that's evil but I
want to you know fight against equality
of outcomes
and it's a hard it's like it literally
during the pandemic
I criticized the The Mask mandate for
two years old you know the ones that
does not even know how to run Quaver
yeah they have to put this mask eight
hours a day
and the children who cannot speak for
themselves we don't even know the what
the wrong term effect on them not seeing
human face and expression in that such
an important crucial year and where
those rich people go to Private Island
have parties with a mask we can afford
our children like I have to work I need
premier daycare where he needs to wear
the mask
and of course I get like censored all of
that but not only that like literally uh
he had a play group and one of the moms
saw it and then told the nanny do not
play with my son
because of my political views do not
play with my own so it's like this is
North Korea like you don't punish family
members because of one person coming
such a certain crime it's okay you know
the collective gift yeah get by
association yeah because my son is
associated to me he is responsible for
my crime yeah and that's what the
comments do do you think we're in a
state of Hysteria in the west that
things calm down since pandemic Hysteria
no not in New York I live in New York I
mean you remember recently the Jordan
Italy who died in Subway who was
convicted 40 times already
and I mean they were just reading the
Subways and Times Square and
it was bad and I think I don't I don't
know how people became dissensible so
uncivilized
you know you talk about equity and it's
really a war of of words and it reminds
me of easily of North Korea the people's
Democratic Republic
of China yeah the whole thing's it's a
it's a they manipulate the manipulation
it's uh it is yeah a word game the
disguise in a concept like safe space
what does that mean yes definitely not
safe if you say one wrong thing how
somebody's feelings you get persecuted
we are inclusive environment definitely
not inclusive complete opposite
subversion of this meanings of work you
know exactly and I think that's what's
scary because in communist countries a
lot of times you don't know what that
means anymore because they got so the
meaning got so inverted and the
governments really hide the meaning of
the words and now in America when you
hear the safe space like of course you
got it on oh dangerous space now it's
inclusive but oh definitely it is not
not inclusive State at all yeah and
America becomes like that now on a more
positive before we start recording we
briefly talked about uh Jordan you
mentioned yeah and he did the forward
for your recent book I understand he's
been a great supporter of yours how
important is he to you as a as a figure
and as a friend
I think in a way like I lost my father
solely and I think I couldn't get those
wisdom and Father's guidance a lot and I
think when I read his book I don't know
why they said he speaks to poor
uneducated white men he spoke so much to
me that book became such a treasure of
my life and it taught me how to be your
parent how to discipline my child he
talks about right and if you don't teach
them to be good on your phone nobody
gonna like your children it's not a
favor to them because they're gonna
suffer why you need to discipline your
kids so people are gonna like them they
get to get positive reinforcement
America teaches different idea it's a
you cannot hurt their feelings don't say
no to your children yeah they literally
have this new pregnancy where if you
want to change your infant life prayer
you need to ask their consent like if I
cannot talk but like they still need to
give you consent now that's why they say
two-year-old can decide their gender
right that's how they've gone so far and
when you read the Dr Pierce book of
course like that's not the case
so it it means so much to me and it's it
really I cannot believe it he can he
supports my work
uh well to continue the positive and and
I I ask a final question which I hope
will have a positive answer is that
you've fled North Korea and but we've
talked a little bit about the problems
you're facing in America yeah will you
be fleeing
the us or do you is there enough of
freedom and enough enough
concept there of a positive future
keeping that you think you want to spend
your future there because the interest
in me that the world is so connected
they're like to me in a way America is
the last hope
not because they're like Norway is
amazing Denmark is amazing it's not in
that way because America was an
experiment right yeah the nation was not
United by the skin color or religion or
the history just the idea yeah that
individuals are created equal we all
deserve the rights to bear arms and
freedom of speech believing in this one
paper of document the Constitution if
you believe in you're American it
doesn't matter where you're born where
you're from what you were doing in the
past if you believe in you get a new
start the opportunity of this land it
was an experiment and it succeeded it
now it's it's questionable what they're
going towards too and that's why I think
I believe in American Dream
I really believe that this idea where we
were pretty equal
and we have opportunity equality of
opportunities not the outcomes
and then Americans can achieve amazing
things the world America has achieved
land of immigration the immigrants came
from such a poor countries fleeing the
Tyranny they came I mean they created
airplanes I mean motion pictures I mean
Tesla and literally now they're creating
Rockets I mean they're taking us to Mars
yes
too but America created way more they
didn't get us tomorrow yes yes
and I think that's why I believe in
American I'm not gonna live this time
because when I was in North Korea what
sudden to me was like I did not know
that I was oppressed
and if you don't know yourself how do
you fight to be free yeah and at least
in America we know that what's going on
we know something is wrong
and I think that's why I see hope not
because there's problems because we know
there is a problem that exists yeah on
that note the only Park an absolute
pleasure to speak with you thank you so
much
and thank you and I'm sure Watchers and
listeners would have found that
fascinating thank you so much
thank you
[Music]